Oh Shit. Hey, we talked about,
remember the last time we talked about
Huawei and it hasn't gone away. No,
it hasn't gotten away. Sees someone
just got arrested yesterday. Two people,
two people. Uh, so, uh, so backstory,
fascinating. This is fascinating. This is,
this is an area I could
definitely disappear down
to Chinese espionage, right?
They go on forever. Once
again, I say, you know,
I talk about are there certain things
that the current administration is doing
that I like? One of them is the way that
they're dealing with China right now.
And yes,
the trade issue is buffeting the market
somewhat and causing some instability.
But again, previous administration, the
Bush administration clinician, lots of,
lots of prep for former presidents.
They all acknowledged that China pub
privately was not a fair trading partner.
This administration's at least trying
to call them out and calling them out on
the, on the, on the cyber
issue too, uh, on their,
on their theft of intellectual
property. So anyway, Huawei, um,
supposedly owned by the founder
and however many employees,
you know, I think Huawei
is, by the way, uh,
the number one telecommunications
equipment manufacturer in the world,
and they're the number two seller
of smartphones right there.
There are bigger seller of smartphones
and apple. So at Samsung, Huawei, apple,
uh,
for this.
And so supposedly the company's owned
by the founder and his daughter is the
chief operating officer, chief
financial officer, one of those.
She was arrested up in Canada,
um,
and she was arrested at the request of
the u s she's up there on bail right now,
waiting extradition,
hearing.
And the reason was because supposedly she
lied about Huawei's dealings with Iran
and they were busting sanctions by
dealing in providing certain types of
equipment to Iran. Now, uh, this, this,
this past week, we've had, uh,
a hallway employee who's now been
fired by hallway, uh, in Poland,
uh,
arrested for espionage.
And along with him is a member of the
Polish intelligence service, right. Who,
uh, retired now and was now working for
a French telecommunications company,
but was arrested also for
a espionage related to a,
uh, and related to this individual
who up until just recently,
it was working for Wallet Wowway Claims
Innocence and says, well, we have no idea.
And the founder just came out and
gave this big speech and said,
I would never let the Chinese
authorities tell me what to do.
And I would certainly never spy on
anybody using quallies capabilities and
technology.
And people are probably thinking,
what the fuck are you talking
about this for? A Huawei and beds,
their telecommunications equipment
throughout the world. Right. So it's in,
uh, uh, our allies, uh,
military operations,
which then are connected to ours,
right.
In terms of communications and transfer
of intelligence and information. Um,
they're everywhere and
it's a chose Poland.
They've been in Poland for about 10 years.
Poland is a very important NATO ally.
So I, I'm, I'm taking a long
time, I realized to explain this,
but what I'm trying to say is nothing
happens by happenstance, right?
The Chinese don't operate that way.
So the Chinese authorities sometime ago,
years ago, looked at it and went, yeah,
this makes sense, right? We've got Huawei,
which by the way, the founder
of a former military, uh,
people's Liberation Army
engineer, um, he, uh,
they, they, they looked at this
and they thought Poland, uh,
that would be a good beach hit for us,
right?
Because there are a key element of NATO,
so let's go to Poland.
So they started a burrowing into
Poland striking deals and you know,
they're basically the most important
foreign relationship now a corporation
inside a Poland and they're fully
embedded and they've had access to, uh,
at this point to NATO communications.
And now the arrest of these two
individuals. And people will still,
despite this and despite their
past, despite their, their,
their theft of information from
everybody from us steel to, uh, to Alcoa,
to Lockheed Martin to dupont,
all the times that they've been stealing
information, people will still go wide.
You know, I don't, I don't believe it.
I don't, that doesn't make any sense.
I don't see why the
Chinese would act that way.
And I don't see why we're being
so harsh on them. You know,
this tariff thing is a bad idea. My
point being, you got to call them out.
They're not going to necessarily
change their behavior,
but you got to raise
public awareness, make, uh,
our allies understanding where
that's what we're doing right now.
We're saying you've gotta you got to put
the brakes on this, build a firewall,
use other companies, telecommunications
equipment, right? Because you know,
the fact that we're
tied in with our allies,
with Poland and with Canada and
know that gives them access to us.
So for someone on the outside,
look, myself was trying
to look at this, and you,
you say that Walway's stealing stuff
like stealing stuff from us steel.
How are they doing that? Well, they, I
mean the u s steel, admittedly that was a,
that was a pla,
that was the People's Liberation Army,
a third department operation
against dupont and,
and also against us steel and others.
So that was a little bit different. I,
I conflated the two,
but Huawei,
one of the things that they do
is by having access, uh, and,
and embedding their equipment
in your communications, um,
infrastructure that gives them
the ability then to, uh, in,
in a simple way to tap in. Right? And it's
a package intercept information, right?
Basically.
So you have communications,
imagine we're trading information
through NATO, uh, channels, right?
All they need is that one in, right?
That's it. It's like everything else,
it's like fishing, right? It's
just like, you know, when,
when hackers just an individual hacker
sitting in somebody's basement, you know,
he just needs that one avenue.
He needs to get one. It's just,
just click on that email that
gives me the pathway in. So when,
when Huawei is able to embed their
technology into Polish communications,
and we're now connected
because of our NATO alliance,
that gives them access to us, to
France, whomever, and yeah. You know,
it's,
it's not as if it just happened.
It's not as if Huawei from a
business perspective, so, you know,
I bet we could sell some of our equipment
in Poland. Wouldn't that be good?
The guy who was arrested,
the Huawei person who was arrested
was responsible for the provision of
telecommunication equipment to
government facilities. That was his job.
And the guy,
the Polish guy,
one of his last jobs with the Intel
service was, uh, communications.
Uh,
so I guess what I'm saying is none of this
shit happens in a bubble and it's all,
it's all very well mapped out.
The Chinese have a very
long view on things and they
are very good at developing
operations like this and so they've
been very successful. Um, so we'll,
we'll, we'll see. But it's, it's,
I'm glad that the current administration
at least is calling them out.
I don't believe it's necessarily going
to change their behavior and that,
you know,
and we'll,
we'll probably get some sort of deal
where they'll claim to look just a couple
of years ago,
they agree with President Obama to stop
their cyber shenanigans and they didn't.
So they just changed the way that
they did it. Um, you know, that's,
that's the world we live in, but I think
it is important to make a stand, right?
Yeah.
There's some that the tech people are
saying that they think it's preposterous.
When they were talking about
the ban on android phones,
some of the tech people say
that doesn't make any sense,
but what you're saying is it goes
far beyond the actual phones itself.
And it's really the,
the mission of the actual company itself.
Yeah. I'm saying that there is no way
that Huawei and, and other important
Chinese companies are
solely privately owned and,
or have,
uh,
the ability to tell the
Chinese authorities that
they will not spy on their
behalf. It just not happening. It's
just not happening. You have to,
you have to go a long ways to come up
with that sort of naive viewpoint that
says that a Chinese company is going to
put its foot down until President Gee,
absolutely not.
We will not do anything to harm another
nation's country or a company or shit
they've spent, they've spent
generations now decades, uh,
jumpstarting their industry and moving
up the food chain on the global economy
by hoovering up everything
possible out there. So if someone,
a tech wizard got ahold
of one of their routers,
can have they been able to
detect something in there
that doesn't belong or some
sort of a back door or some sort
of a way that they could tap in.
It's like if you were,
you know,
you were apple and you were sending
data to Raytheon or whatever and you're
going back and forth,
they could tap in through that as it had
been proven that there's a device like
that.
Yeah.
A former NSA director Mcconnell back in,
uh,
2015, I think early 2015, um,
came out and NSA came out with an official
statement and it said every major US
corporation of any has been, um, uh,
attacked and exploited by Chinese.
And we have never,
ever not found Chinese malware
within their systems. Wow.
That was over four years going out for
malware being software. Right, right,
right. Is there anything in the
hardware itself? Uh, yes. In, in,
in a sense that, um, yes,
in, in the sense of like,
I'm trying to remember the,
the name of it, but not
doing a very good job. Um,
if you have,
uh,
access to or understanding
of physical hardware,
um, then you can, uh, affect
easier, you can affect,
um, physical control of systems.
Right. So, uh, stuxnet, remember,
I don't know if you remember stuxnet
was a dude, but it was exactly,
it was an attack on Iran. Um,
the shut down their nuclear
program. Right, exactly.
To, uh, essentially what it did was it
took over control of some centrifuges, uh,
over spun them that he did about broke.
And it was a virus and it was,
it was an piece of software
that was able to impact the,
the, you know, physical equipment. Uh,
it took control of those
systems because in part, uh,
whoever perpetrated it had much better
understanding of that gear. Right.
Or had access to that gear. And that's
a, that's an important part of, of this.
And it's happened several times
since then. And I'm, you know,
I'm not disclosing anything because
it's all it's been written about.
I'm sure it will be a movie at
some point, but, um, that is, uh,
that's a concern. I'm far more worried
about a company like Huawei with,
it's a integration into allied,
um,
our allies,
uh,
telecommunications systems than I am about
sort of the individual sale of phones.
And you know what that
means? Look, you know,
Amazon and all the others are gathering
more data on the average American than,
you know,
uh,
US government or anybody else's
government is doing it at this point.